The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, welcome back.
This is the second half of our
two lectures on distributed
algorithms this week.
I could turn that on, OK.
All right, I'll start
with a quick preview.
This week, we're just looking
at synchronous and asynchronous
distributed algorithms,
not worrying
about interesting
stuff like failures.
Last time we looked
at leader election,
maximal independent set,
breadth-first spanning trees,
and we started looking
at shortest paths trees.
We'll finish that
today, and then we'll
move on to the main topic for
today, which is asynchronous
distributed algorithms where
things start getting much more
complicated because not
everything is going on
in synchronous rounds.
And we'll revisit the same
two problems, breadth-first
and shortest paths
spanning trees.
Quick review, all
of our algorithms
are using a model that's
based on undirected graph.
Using this notation, gamma,
for the neighbors of a vertex.
We'll talk about the
degree of a vertex.
We have a process,
then, associated
with every vertex in the graph.
And we associate
communication channels
in both directions
on every edge.
Last time we looked at
synchronous distributed
algorithms in the
synchronous model.
We have the processes
of the ground vertices,
they communicate using messages.
The processes have
local ports that they
know by some kind of
local name, and the ports
connect to their
communication channel.
The algorithm executes
in synchronous rounds
where, in every
around, every process
is going to decide what to
send on all of its ports,
and the messages then get put
into the channel delivered
to the processes
at the other end.
And everybody looks at all the
messages they get at that round
all at once, and they
determine a new state.
They compute a new
state based on all
of those arriving messages.
We started with leader election.
I won't repeat the
problem definition,
but here's the results
that we got last time.
We looked at a special
case of a graph that's
just a simple clique.
And if the processes don't have
any distinguishing information,
like unique identifiers,
and they're deterministic,
then there's no way to break
the symmetry and you can prove
an impossibility result
that says that you
can't-- in a deterministic,
indistinguishable case,
you can't guarantee to elect a
leader in this kind of a graph.
Just as an aside, I should
say that distributed computing
theory is just filled with
impossibility results,
and they're all based on this
limitation of distributed
computing where
each node only knows
what's happening to itself
and in its neighborhood.
Nobody knows what's happening
in the entire system.
That's a very strong limitation,
and as you might expect,
that would make a lot of
things impossible or difficult.
Then we went on and got two
positive results, a theorem
that-- well, an algorithm
that is deterministic,
but the processes have
unique identifiers,
and then you can elect
a leader quickly.
Or if you don't have
unique identifiers
but you have probability, so
you can make random choices,
you can essentially
choose an identifier,
and then it works almost as
well with those identifiers.
Then we looked at
maximal independent set.
Remember what it
means, no two neighbors
should both be in
the set, but you
don't want to be able to add
any more nodes while keeping
these nodes independent.
In other words, every
node is either in the set
or has a neighbor in the set.
And we gave this algorithm--
I'm just including it here
as a reminder-- Luby's
algorithm, which basically goes
through a number of phases.
In each phase, some processes
decide to join the MIS
and their neighbors
decide not to join,
and you just repeat this.
You do this based on
choosing random IDs again.
And we proved that the theorem
correctly computes an MIS,
and with a good
probability, all the nodes
decide within only
logarithmic phases,
and here is the number of nodes.
All right, then went on to
breadth-first spanning trees.
Here, we have now a graph
that already has a leader.
It has a distinguished vertex.
And the process
that's sitting there
knows that it's the leader.
The processes now
are going to produce
a breadth-first spanning
tree rooted at that vertex.
Now, for the rest
of the time, we'll
assume unique identifiers,
but the processes
don't know anything about the
graph except that their own ID
and their neighbors' IDs.
And we want the processes
to eventually output
the ID of their parent.
And here is, just to repeat, the
simple algorithm that we used.
Basically, it's processes
just mark themselves
as they get included
in the tree.
It starts out with just
the root being marked.
He sends a special search
message out to his neighbors,
and soon as they get it they
get marked and pass it on.
Everybody gets
marked in a number
of rounds that corresponds to
their depth in-- their distance
from the root of the tree,
[INAUDIBLE] from the tree.
We talked about correctness
in terms of invariance.
What this algorithm
guarantees is,
at the end of any number r of
rounds, exactly the processes
at distance up to r are
marked, and the processes that
are marked, have
their parents defined.
And if your parents
defined-- it's
the UID of a process that
has distance d minus 1
from the root.
If you're a distance
d, your parent
should be somebody
who's correct--
has the correct
distance d minus 1.
We analyze the complexity.
Time is counting the
number of rounds.
And that's going
to be, at worst,
the diameter of the network.
It's really the distance from
a particular vertex, v 0.
And the message
complexity-- there's
only one message sent in
each direction on each edge,
so that's going to be only
order of the number of edges.
And we talked about how
you can get child pointers.
This just gives you parents.
But if you want to also
find out your children,
then every search
message should get
a response either
saying you're my parent
or you're not my parent.
And we can do a termination
using convergecast,
and there's some applications
we talked about as well.
All right, and then at
the end of the hour,
we started talking
about a generalization,
a breadth-first spanning trees,
which adds weights so you
have shortest paths trees.
Now you have weights
on the edges.
Processes still have
unique identifiers.
They don't know anything
about the graph,
except their immediate
neighborhood information.
And they have to produce
a shortest path spanning
tree rooted at vertex v 0.
You know what a spanning tree
is and the shortest paths
are in terms of the
total weight of the path.
Now we want each node each,
process, to output its parent
in the shortest path.
And also the distance from
the original vertex v 0.
At the end of the
hour, we looked
at a version of Bellman-Ford,
which you've already
seen as a sequential algorithm.
But as a distributed
algorithm, everybody
keeps track of their best
guess, their best current guess,
of the distance from
the initial vertex.
And they keep track
of their parent
on some path that gave it
this distance estimate,
and they keep their
unique identifier.
The complete algorithm
now is, everybody's
going to keep sending
their distance around-- I
mean we could optimize
that, but this is simple.
At every round, everybody sends
their current distance estimate
to all their neighbors.
They collect the
distance estimates
from all their neighbors, and
then they do a relaxation step.
If they get anything
that's better
than what they had before, they
look at the best new estimate
they could get.
They take the minimum of their
old estimate-- stop shaking,
good-- and the minimum
of all of the estimates
they would get by looking
at the incoming information
plus adding the weight of
the edge between the sender
and the node itself.
This way you may get
a better estimate.
And if you do, you
would reset your parent
to be the sender of this
improved information.
And again, you can
pick-- if there's a tie,
you can pick any
of the nodes that
sense-- the information
leading to the best new guess,
you can set your
parent to any of those.
And then this just repeats.
At the very end of the hour,
we showed an animation,
which I'm not going
to repeat now,
which basically shows how you
can get lots of corrections.
You can have many
paths that are set up
that look good after
just one round,
but then they get corrected
as the rounds go on.
You get much lower
weight paths by having
a roundabout, multi-hop
path to a node.
You can get a better total cost.
Here's where we
got to last time.
Now why does this work?
Well what we need is
eventually every process
should get the correct distance.
And the parent should be its
predecessor on some shortest
path.
In order to prove that-- you
always look for an invariant,
something that's true,
at intermediate steps
of the algorithm that you can
show by induction will hold--
and that will imply the result
that you want at the end.
Here, what's the key invariant?
At the end of some number r of
rounds, what do processes have?
After r rounds have passed,
in this kind of algorithm,
what do the estimates look like?
Well, after one
round, everybody's
got their best estimate
that could happen
on a single-- that could
result from a single hop path
from v 0.
After two rounds, you
also get the best guesses
from two hop paths, and
after r rounds in general,
you have your distance
and parent corresponding
to a shortest path
chosen from among those
that have at most our hops.
Yes?
That makes sense?
No?
Yeah?
OK.
All right, and if there is
no path of r hops or fewer
to get to a node,
there's still going
to have their distance estimate
be infinity after r rounds.
This is not a complete proof,
but it's the key invariant
that makes this work.
You can see that after
enough rounds corresponding
to the number of
nodes, for example,
everybody will have the correct
shortest path of any length.
OK?
The number of rounds
until every estimate
stabilize-- all the
estimates stabilize,
it's going to be n minus 1.
All right?
Because the longest
simple path to any node
is going to be n
minus 1, if it goes
through all the nodes of the
network before reaching it.
Makes sense?
If you want to make sure
you have the best estimate,
you have to wait
n minus 1 rounds
to make sure the
information has reached you.
The message complexity--
well, since there's
all these repeated estimates
it's no longer just
proportional to the
number of edges,
but you have to
take into account
that there can be many new
estimates sent on each edge.
In fact, the way
I've written this,
you just keep sending your
distance at every round.
It's going to be
the number of edges
times the number of rounds.
You can do somewhat
better than this,
but it's worse than just
the simple BFS case.
This is more expensive, because
BFS just had diameter rounds
and this now has n
for n minus 1 rounds,
and BFS just had one message
ever sent on each edge,
and now we have to send many.
Comments?
Questions?
Is it clear that the time bound
really does depend on n and not
on the diameter?
For breadth-first search,
it was enough just
to have enough
rounds to correspond
to the actual distance
and hops to each node,
but now you need
enough rounds to take
care of these
indirect paths that
might go through many nodes but
still end up with a shorter--
with a smaller total weight.
Is it clear to everybody
why the bound depends on n?
Actually the animation
that I had last time
showed how there are
lots of corrections,
and you had enough-- you
had rounds that depended
on the total number of nodes.
Yes?
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But could you
keep track of each round
if the values-- if
any of [INAUDIBLE]?
If you-- if everything stops
changing after less than n
rounds, then you
might not have to--
PROFESSOR: OK, so you're
asking about termination?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Ah, OK, well so
that's probably the next slide.
First, let's deal with
the child pointers,
and then we'll come
back to termination.
First, this just gives
you your parents.
If you want your children,
you can do the same thing
that we did last time.
When a process gets a message,
and the message doesn't
make the sender its
parent, this is not
giving it an improved distance.
Then the node can just
respond, non-parent.
But if a process
receives a message that
doesn't improve the distance,
it says, OK, you are my parent,
but it might have also
told another node--
it might have another
parent, another node
that previously it
thought was its parent.
It has to do more
work, in this case,
to correct the erroneous
parent information.
It has to send its previous
parent a non-parent message
to correct the previous
parent message.
Things are getting a
little bit trickier here.
On the other end, if somebody is
keeping track of its children,
it has to make adjustments
too because things can
change during the algorithm.
Let's say a process keeps track
of its children in some set,
it has a set children.
If it gets a non-parent
message from a child,
even if that child might
be from a neighbor.
That neighbor might be
in its set children,
and this could be a
correction, and then
the process has to
take that neighbor out
of the set of children.
And suppose the process
improves its own distance.
Well, now, it's kind
of starting over.
It's going to send that
distance to all of its neighbors
again and collect
new information about
whether they're children or not.
The simple thing to do
here is just empty--
zero out your children
set and start over.
Now you send your new
messages to your neighbors
and wait for them
to respond again.
There's tricky bookkeeping
to do to handle corrections
as the structure of
this tree changes,
so getting child pointers
is a little more complicated
than before.
Make sense?
All right, so now back to
your question, termination.
How do all the processes know
when the tree is complete?
In fact, we have
a worse problem.
With this problem we hit
for breadth first search,
but we have an
even worse problem.
Now what is that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, before we
had each individual node.
Once it figured out
who its parent was,
it could just output that.
And now, you can figure out your
parent, but it's just a guess
and you don't know when
you can output this.
How does a process even--
an individual process
even figure out its own
parent and distance?
There's two aspects
here in termination.
One is how do you know the
whole thing is finished,
but the other one
is even how do you
know when you're done with
your own parent and distance?
Well, if you knew
something about the graph,
like an upper bound on
the total number of nodes,
then you could just wait
until that number of rounds
and be done.
But what if you don't have that
information about the graph?
What might you do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You want
to BFS in parallel
and filter down the
information when you've
reached the size of the graph.
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
I think-- what is the strategy
we use for termination for BFS?
Let's start with that one.
It's a little easier.
You did the subtree
thing that we call
convergecast the information.
When we had a leaf he
knew he was a leaf,
and he could send his done
information up to his parent
and that got convergecast
up to the top of the tree.
Can we convergecast
in this setting?
Turns out we can, but
since things are changing,
you're going to be
sending done messages
and then something might change.
You might be participating in
the convergecast many times.
Since the tree
structure is changing,
the main idea is anybody
can send a done message
to it's current-- the node
he believes is his parent,
provided he's received responses
to all of its distance messages
so it thinks it knows
who all its children are.
It has a current estimate
of all the children
and-- so if it knows
all its children
and they have all sent
him done messages.
For all your current
children, your current belief
or who your children
are, if they've all
sent you done messages, then
you can send a done message
up the tree.
But this can get a
little more complicated
than it sounds, because you can
change who your children are.
What this means is
that the same process
can be involved several
times in the convergecast,
based on improving
the estimates.
Here's an example of the kind
of thing that can happen.
Let's say you start out,
you have these huge weights
and then you have a long
path with small weights.
i 0 starts out and sends
its distance information
on its three nodes, to
its three neighbors.
And this guy at the bottom now
has a distance estimate of 100,
and it's going to
decide it's a leaf.
Why?
Because when it sends
messages to its children,
to its neighbors, they're not
able to improve their estimates
based on the new information
that he's sending.
This guy decides that
he's a leaf right away,
and he sends that
information back to node i 0.
On the other hand, this guy
has the same estimate of 100.
And he sends out his messages to
try to find out if he's a leaf,
but he finds out when he
sends a message this way
that he's actually able
to improve that neighbor's
estimate, because that
was infinity till then.
He doesn't think he's a leaf.
We have this one guy who thinks
he's a leaf and responds,
so this i 0 is sitting there.
He has to wait to hear
from his other children.
OK so far?
All right, in the
meantime, the messages
are going to
eventually creep around
and this node is going to
get a smaller estimate based
on the length of that
long many hop path.
Then he's going to decide
he is not a child of i 0.
He's going to tell
i 0 I'm really not
your child, which means that
i 0 stops waiting for him.
But also, this guy decides
he's not a child as well.
He becomes a child of
the node right above him.
So i 0 now will realize
he only has one child,
but this guy believes he's a
leaf again after trying again
to find children.
And now the done information
propagates all the way
up the tree, which is now
just this one long path.
They start trying
to convergecast,
but then, oops, they were wrong.
They have to make a
correction, and they
are forming a new tree.
Eventually, the tree
is going to stabilize,
and eventually the
done information
will get all the
way up to the top,
but there could be lots of
false starts in the mean time.
It's sort of
confusing, but that's
the kind of thing that happens.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There may be a
process in which [INAUDIBLE]
and then it just switches its
mind at the very end of it.
How do you make sure that,
that propagation [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so
the root node isn't
going to terminate until
it hears from everybody.
You kind of have to close
out the whole process.
It's always pending,
waiting for somebody,
if it hasn't heard from someone.
If things switch, they'll join
in another part of the tree.
I think the best
thing to do here
is sort of construct some
little examples by hand.
I mean we're not going
to get into it how
you do formal proofs
of things like this.
We don't even have
right now a simulator
you can use to play
with these algorithms.
Although if
anybody's interested,
some students in
my class last term,
actually, wrote a simulator
that might be available.
OK, all right, so
that's what you
get for a synchronous-- some
example synchronous distributed
algorithms.
Now let's look at
something more complicated
when you get into
asynchronous algorithms.
OK.
So far complications
that you've seen
over the rest of
this course, you
have now processes that
are acting concurrently.
And we had a little
bit of non-determinism,
nothing important,
but now things
are about to get much worse.
We don't have rounds anymore.
Now we're going to have
processes taking steps,
messages getting delivered at
absolutely arbitrary times,
arbitrary orders.
The processes can get
completely out of sync,
and so you have lots and
lots more non-determinism
in the algorithm.
The non-determinism
has to do with who's
doing what in what order.
Understanding that
type of algorithm
is really different from
understanding the algorithms
that you've seen all term and
even synchronous distributed
algorithms, because
there isn't just one way
the algorithm is
going to execute.
The execution can proceed
in many different ways,
just depending on the
order of the steps.
You can't ever
hope to understand
exactly how this kind of
algorithm is executing.
What can you do?
Well, you can play with
it, but in the end,
you have to understand is
some abstract properties.
Some properties of
the executions, rather
than exactly what happens at
every step, and that's a jump.
It's a new way of thinking.
We can look at
asynchronous stuff,
if you want, from my book.
Now we still have processes
at the nodes of a graph.
And now we have
communication channels
associated with the edges.
Now, the processes are going
to be some kind of automata,
but the channels will also
be some kind of automata.
We'll have all these
components, and we'll
be modeling all of them.
Processes still
have their ports.
They need not, in
general, have identifiers.
What's a channel?
A channel is-- it's a kind of
an automaton, infinite state
automaton, that has
inputs and some outputs.
Here, this is just a picture
of a channel from node u
to node v. Channel
uv is just this cloud
thing that delivers messages.
It has inputs.
The inputs are-- messages
get sent on the channel.
You can have one process at
one end sending a message m
and the outputs at the other
end are the deliveries,
let's say receive message
m, at the other end, node v.
To model this, the
best thing is actually
to-- instead of
just describing what
it does, to give an
explicit model of its state
and what happens when the
inputs and outputs occur.
If you want these messages
to be delivered-- let's
say in FIFO order, fine.
You can make the state of
the channel be an actual q.
mq would just be a
FIFO queue of messages.
Starts out empty, and
when messages get sent,
they get added to the end,
and get delivered they
get removed from the beginning.
All that we need
to describe-- this
is a sort of a pseudo code.
All we need to describe--
to write in order
to describe what
this channel does,
is what happens
when a send occurs,
and when can this channel
deliver a message, and what
happens when it does that.
A send, which can just come
in at any time, and the effect
is just to add this message
to the end of the queue.
The recieve-- stop moving.
The receive-- that
cannot be construction.
We'd hear noise.
It's gremlins.
We have-- a receive
can occur only
when this message is at
the head of the queue,
and when it occurs, it gets
removed from the queue.
Does this make sense
as a description
of what a channel does?
Messages come in,
get added to it,
and then messages
can get delivered
in certain situations,
and they get removed.
That's a description
of the channel.
to be using an
asynchronous system.
A process-- the
rest of the system
consists of processes associated
with the graph vertices.
Let's say pu is a process
that's associated with vertex u.
But I'm writing that just sort
of as a shorthand, because u
is the vertex in the graph, and
the process doesn't actually
know the name of the vertex.
It just has its own
unique ID or something,
but I'm going to be a little
sloppy about that now.
The process that at
vertex u can perform
send outputs to put
messages on the channel,
and it will receive
inputs for messages
to come in on the channel.
But the processes might also
have some external interface
where somebody is submitting
some inputs to the process,
and the process has to produce
some output at the end.
There can be other
inputs and outputs.
And we'll model it
with state variables.
Process is supposed
to keep taking steps.
The channel is supposed to
keep delivering messages.
It's a property called liveness.
You want to make sure that
your components in your system
all keep doing things.
They don't just do some
steps and then stop.
Here's a simple example.
A process that's remembering the
maximum number it's ever seen.
There's a max process automaton.
It receives some
messages m, some value,
and it will send it out.
It keeps track of the max--
that's max state variable.
it starts out with its
own initial values,
so x for u. x of u
is its initial value.
And then it has--
for every neighbor,
it has a little queue--
here, it's just a Boolean--
asking whether it's supposed
to send to that neighbor.
This is the pseudocode
for that max process.
What does it do when
it receives a message?
Well, it sees if that value is
bigger than what it had before,
and if so, it resets the max.
And it also makes a note that
it's supposed to send this out
to all its neighbors.
Whenever it gets
new information,
it will want to propagate
it to its neighbors.
You see how this is written?
You just say, reset the
max and then get ready
to send to all your
neighbors, and the last part
is just sort of trivial code.
It says, if you are ready
to send, then you can send,
and then you're done and you
can set the send flags to false.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What study?
PROFESSOR: For every neighbor.
Oh, I wrote neighbor v
before, and then I-- yeah.
I wrote neighbor-- oh,
I know why I wrote w.
Here, I'm talking about
if you receive a message
from a particular
neighbor v, then
you have to send it
to all your neighbors.
Before, I used v to
denote a generic neighbor,
but now I can't do
that anymore, because v
is the sender of the message.
Just technical-- OK?
We have these process automata.
We have this channel automata.
Now, we want to
build the system.
We paste them together.
How we paste them
is just we have
outputs from processes that
can match up with inputs
to channels and vice versa.
If a process has a
send output, let's
say send from u to v, that will
match up with the channel that
has send uv as an input.
And the receive from
the channel matches up
with the process that has
that receive as an input.
All I'm doing is matching
up these components.
I'm hooking together
these components
by matching up
their action names.
Does that make sense?
I'm saying how I build a system
out of all these components,
and I just have a syntactic way
of saying what actions match up
in different components.
Questions?
This is all new.
When this system
takes a step, well,
if somebody's
performing an action,
and someone else has
that same action--
let's say a process
is doing a send.
The channel has a send.
They both take their
transitions at the same time.
The process sends
a message, it gets
put into the channel at
the end of its queue.
Make sense?
OK.
How does this thing execute?
Well, there's no
synchronous rounds,
so the system just
operates by the processes
and the channels just perform
their steps in any order.
One at a time, but it
can be in any order,
so it's a sequence model.
You just have a sequence
of individual steps.
There's no concurrency here.
In the synchronous model, we
had everybody taking their steps
in one big block.
And here, it's just they
take steps one at a time,
but it could be in any order.
And we have to make sure that
everybody keeps taking steps.
That every channel continues
to deliver messages,
and every process
always performs
some step that's enabled.
For the max processes,
well, we can just
have a bunch of processes,
each one now starting
with its initial value.
And what happens when we
plug them together with all
their channels between them?
Corresponding to whatever
graph they are in.
They just have
channels on the edges.
What's the behavior of this?
If all the processes are like
the ones I just showed you,
they wait till they
hear some new max
and then they send it out.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: All
processes eventually
have a globally maximum value.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, they'll all
eventually get the global max.
They'll keep propagating
until everybody receives it.
Here's a animation if everybody
starts with the values that
are written in these circles.
Now, remember,
before they were all
sending it once, now no more.
Let's say the first
thing that happens
is the process that started
with five sends its message out
on one of its channels,
so the five goes out.
The next thing that might
happen is the other process
with the seven might
send the seven out
on one of its channels.
And these are three more steps.
Somebody sends a 10.
Somebody sends a seven.
Somebody received a message and
updated its value as a result,
and we continue.
I'm depicting several
steps at once,
because it's boring to
really do them one at a time,
but the model really says that
they take steps in some order.
Everybody is propagating
the largest thing it's seen,
and eventually, you wind
up with everybody having
the maximum value, the 10.
All right, that's how an
asynchronous system operates.
We can analyze the message
complexity of this.
The total number
of messages sent
during the entire execution,
at worst, on every edge.
You can send the successively
improved estimate,
so that's, again, what are
n times the number of edges.
Time complexity is an issue.
When we had
synchronous algorithms,
we just counted the number
of rounds and that was easy.
But what do we measure now?
How do we count the time when
you have all these processes
and channels taking
steps whenever they want?
Yeah, so this really
isn't obvious.
There's a solution that's
commonly used, which is-- OK,
we're going to use real time.
And we're going to
make some assumptions
about certain basic
steps taking, at most,
a certain amount of time.
Let's say that local
computational-- time
for a process to perform
its next step, is little l.
You just give a
local time bound.
And then you have d for a
channel to deliver one message.
The first message that's
currently in the channel.
If you have
assumptions like that,
you could use those to infer
a real time upper bound
for solving the whole problem.
I mean if you know it takes no
longer than d to deliver one
message, then you
can bound how long
it takes to deliver-- to empty
out a queue, a channel, and how
long it takes for messages to
propagate through the network.
It's tricky, but this
is about the only thing
you can do in a setting
where you don't actually
have rounds to measure.
Then for the max system,
how long does it take?
Well, let's just ignore
the local processing time.
Usually that's assumed
to be very small,
so let's say it's 0.
We can get a very simple,
pessimistic really,
upper bound that says the
real time for finishing
the whole thing is of the order
of the diameter of the network
times the number of
nodes times little
d is the amount of time
for a message queue
to deliver its first message.
As a naive way of
analyzing this,
you just consider how
long it takes for the max
to reach some particular vertex
u along the shortest path.
Well, it has to go through
all the hops on the path,
so that would be the diameter.
And how long does it have
to wait in each channel
before it gets to
move another hop?
Well, it might be at
the end of a queue.
How big could the queue be?
Well, at worst end for
the improved estimates.
Let's say it's n times the
delivery time on the channel,
just to traverse one channel.
What I'm doing is modeling
possible congestion
on the queue to see how
long it takes for a message
to traverse one channel.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are we just assuming
that processes process things,
and messages are delivered
as soon as they can possibly
have them?
PROFESSOR: Good.
Yeah, we normally have--
I'm sort of skipping over
some things in the model-- but
you have a liveness assumption
that says that the process
keeps taking steps as long
as it has anything
to do, and so we
would be putting time
bounds on how long
it takes between those steps.
That'll be the local
processing time, here.
I'm saying that's 0.
AUDIENCE: You do
that-- wouldn't you
be able to get some
amount of information
about what were
things happening?
PROFESSOR: Ah, OK.
Here is-- this is a
very subtle point.
What do you think is that if
I'm making all these timing
assumptions, the
processes should
be able to figure that out.
But actually, you can't
figure anything out just
based on these assumptions
about these upper bounds.
Putting upper bounds on
the time between steps
does not in any way
restrict the orderings.
You still have all the same
possible orderings of steps.
Nobody can see
anything different.
These times are not
visible in any sense.
They're not marked anywhere
for the processes to read.
They're just
something that we're
using to evaluate the cost, the
time cost, of the execution.
And you're not
restricting the execution
by putting just upper
bounds on the time.
If you are restricting
the execution,
like you had upper bounds and
lower bounds on the time, then
the processes might
know a lot more.
They might, in fact, be acting
more like a synchronous system.
These are times that are just
used for analyzing complexity.
They're not anything known to
the processes in the system.
OK?
All right.
Now let's revisit the
breadth-first spanning tree
problem.
We want to now compute a
breadth-first spanning tree
in an asynchronous network.
Connected graph,
distinguish root vertex,
processes have no
knowledge of the graph.
They have you UIDs.
All this is the same as before
in the synchronous case.
Everybody's supposed to
output its parent information
when it's done.
Here's an idea.
Suppose we just take that nice
simple synchronous algorithm
that I reviewed at the beginning
of the hour where everybody
just sends a search message
as soon as they get it
and they just adopt the
first parent they see.
What happens if I run
that asynchronously?
I just send it and I
get a search message.
Then I send it out to
my parents whenever
and everybody's doing this.
Whenever they get their
first search message,
they decide the
sender is its parent.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could you
possibly have a front tier
that doesn't keep expanding--
not obeying the defining
property of the BFS?
PROFESSOR: Yeah
it could be that,
because we don't have
any restriction on how
fast the messages might be
sent and the order of steps,
it could be that some
messages get sent
very quickly on some long path.
Someone sitting at the far
end of the network might
get a message first
on a long path
and later on a short
path, and the first one to
gets it decides that's its
parent, then it's stuck.
This is not an algorithm
that makes corrections.
OK?
All right, well, before we had
a little bit of non-determinism
when we had this algorithm
in the synchronous case
because we could have two
messages arriving at once,
and you have to pick
one to be your parent.
Now that doesn't
happen, because you only
get one message at a time,
but you have a lot more
non-determinism now.
Now you have all
this non-determinism
from the order in which the
messages get sent and processes
take their steps.
There's plenty of
non-determinism,
and remember, the way we treat
non-determinism for distributed
algorithms is it's
supposed to work
regardless of how those
non-deterministic choices get
made.
How would we describe?
I'll just write some
pseudo code here
for a process that's
just mimicking
the trivial algorithm.
It can receive a search
message, that's the inputs,
and it can send a search
message as its output.
It can also output parent
when it's ready to do that.
What does it have
to keep track of?
Well, it keeps
track of its parent,
keeps track of whether
it's reported its parent,
and it has some send
buffers with messages
it's ready to send
to its neighbors,
could be search
messages or nothing.
This bottom symbol is
just a placeholder symbol.
What happens when the process
receives a search message, just
following the simple algorithm?
Well, if it doesn't
have a parent yet,
then it sets its parent to
be the sender of that search
message, and it gets ready
to send the search message
to all of its neighbors.
That's really the
heart of the algorithm
that you saw for
the simple algorithm
for that is the synchronous
case so that's the same code.
The rest of the code is it just
sends the search messages out
when it's got them
in the send buffers,
and it can announce its
parent once the parent is set,
and then it doesn't-- this
flag just means it doesn't keep
announcing it over
and over again.
It makes sense
that this describes
that simple algorithm.
It's pretty concise,
just what does
it do in all these
different steps.
OK?
Now, if you run
this asynchronously,
as you already
noted, it isn't going
to necessarily work right.
You can have this guy
sending search messages,
but some are going to
arrive faster than others.
And you see you can have the
search messages creeping around
in an indirect
path, which causes
a spanning tree like
this one to be created,
which is definitely not a
breadth-first spanning tree.
The breadth-first tree is this
one-- a breadth-first tree.
You have these roundabout paths.
This doesn't work.
What do we do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could have
a child [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You're going to try
to synchronize them, basically.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That is related to
a homework question this week.
Very good.
We're going to do
something different.
Other suggestions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: We could keep a
variable in each process
that-- you can do something
like Bellman-Ford.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so you can do
what we did for Bellman-Ford,
but now the setting is
completely different.
We did it for Bellman-Ford
when it was synchronous
and we had weights.
Now, it's asynchronous
and there are no weights.
OK?
Oh, there's some remarks
on a couple of slides here.
This is just
belaboring the point,
that the paths that you
get by this algorithm
can be longer than
the shortest paths,
and-- yeah, you can analyze the
message and time complexity.
The complexity here is order of
the diameter times the message
delay on one link.
And why is it the diameter
even though some paths
may be very long?
This is a real time
upper bound that
depends on the actual
diameter of the graph,
not on the total
number of nodes.
Why would an upper bound on
the running time for the simple
algorithm depend
on the diameter?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because you
only have a longer path
if it's faster than--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
The way we're modeling
it-- it's a little strange,
maybe-- but we're
saying that something
can travel on a long path
only if it's going very fast.
But the actual shortest paths
still move along, at worst,
at d time per hop.
At worst, the shortest
path information
would get there within time d.
Something is going to
get there within time d,
even though something else
might get there faster.
OK?
All right.
Yes, we can set up
a child pointers,
and we can do termination
using convergecast.
It's just one tree.
There's nothing changing here.
And applications,
same as before.
But that didn't
work, so we're going
to-- back to the
point we were talking
about a minute ago-- we're
going to use a relaxation
algorithm like Bellman-Ford.
In the synchronous
case, we corrected
for paths that had many
hops but low weight,
but now we're going to correct
for the asynchrony errors.
All the errors that you get
because of things traveling
fast on long paths, we're
going to correct for those
using the same strategy.
Everybody is going to keep
track of the hop distance.
No weights now just
the hop distance,
and they will change
the parent when
they learn of a shorter path.
And then they will propagate
the improved distance,
so it's exactly
like Bellman-Ford.
And eventually,
this will stabilize
to an actual breadth-first
spanning tree.
Here's a description
of this new algorithm.
Everybody keeps track
of their parent,
and now they keep track
of their hop distance,
and they have their channels.
Here's the key, when you get
new information-- you receive
some new information,
this m is a number
of hops that your
neighbor is telling you.
Well, if m plus
1, which would be
your new estimate
for a number of
hops-- if that's better
than what you already have,
then you just
replace your estimate
by this new number of hops.
And you set your--
to a new parent.
You set your parent
pointer to the sender,
and you propagate
this information.
It's exactly the same
as what we had before,
but now we're correcting
for the asynchrony.
We get shorter hop paths later.
Makes sense?
And the rest of this is
just you send the message.
And notice we don't have
any terminating actions.
Why?
Because we have the
same problem that we
had before with having processes
know when they're done.
If you keep get
getting corrections,
how do you know when
you're finished?
And how do you know
this is going to work?
In the synchronous
case, we could
get an exact characterization
of what exactly
the situation is after
any number of rounds.
And we can't do that
now, because things
can happen in so many orders.
We have to, instead,
state some higher level
abstract properties,
either in variance
or you'll see some other
kinds of properties as well.
We could say, for
instance, as an invariant,
that all the distance
information you get is correct.
If you ever have your
distance set to something,
it's the actual
distance on some path
and your parent is correctly set
to be your predecessor on such
a path.
This is just saying whatever
you get is correct information.
This doesn't say that eventually
you're going to finish, though.
It just says what
you get is correct.
If you want to show
that, eventually, you
get the right answer,
you have to do something
with the timing.
You have to say something
like by a certain time that
depends on the distance.
If there is-- and at most
our hop path to a node,
then it will learn about
that by a certain time,
but that depends on the length
of the path and the message
delivery time.
And the number of nodes,
because they can be congestion.
You have to not only
say things are correct,
but you have to say, eventually,
you get the right result,
and here it will say by
a certain time you get
the right result. Makes sense?
This is how you would understand
an algorithm like this one.
Message complexity.
Since there's all
these corrections,
you're back in number
of edges times possibly
the number of nodes.
And the time complexity, till
all the distances and parent
values stabilize,
could be-- this
is pessimistic
again-- the diameter
times the number of nodes
times d, because there
can be congestion in
each of the links because
of the corrections.
How do you know
when this is done?
How can a process know
when it can finish?
Idea?
Before we had said,
well, if you knew n,
if you knew the
number of nodes, you
could weight that
number of rounds.
That doesn't even help you here.
Even if you know--
have a good upper bound
on the number of
nodes in the network,
there's no rounds to count.
You can't tell.
Even knowing the number
of nodes you can't tell,
so how might you
detect termination?
Yep?
AUDIENCE: It could bound on
the diameter of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, well,
but even if you know
that, you can't count time.
See this is the thing about
asynchronous algorithms,
you don't have--
although we're using time
to measure how long
it's termination takes,
we-- the processes in
there don't have that.
They're just these asynchronous
guys who just take their steps.
They're ignorant of
anything to do with time.
Other ideas?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't you use the
same converge kind of thing--
PROFESSOR: Same thing.
We're just going to use
convergecast again, same idea.
You just compute and your
repute your child pointers.
You send a done to your current
parent, after you've gotten
responses to all
your messages, so you
think you know your children.
And they've all told
you they're done
and-- but then you might
have to make corrections,
so as in what we saw
before, you can be involved
in this convergecast several
times until it finally reaches
all the way to the root.
Once you have these, you can
use them the same way as before.
You now have costs
that are better
than this simple tree
that didn't have shortest
paths, because it now
takes you less time to use
the tree for computing functions
or disseminating information
because the tree is shallower.
Finally, what
happens when we want
to find shortest path trees
in an asynchronous setting?
Now, we're going to add
to the complications
that we just saw with
all the asynchrony.
The complications of having
weights on the edges.
All right, the problem is get
a shortest path spanning tree,
now in an asynchronous
network, weighted graph,
processes don't know
about the graph again.
They have UIDs, and everybody's
supposed to output its distance
and parent in the tree.
We're going to use another
relaxation algorithm.
Now think about
what the relaxation
is going to be doing for you.
We have two kinds of
corrections to make.
You could have long paths
that have small weight.
That showed up for Bellman-Ford
in the synchronous setting,
so we have to correct for those.
But you could also have--
because of asynchrony,
you could have information
travelling fast on many hops,
and you have to correct
for that as well.
There's two kinds
of things you're
going to be correcting
for in one algorithm.
This is going to-- and it's
pretty surprising-- it's
going to lead to ridiculously
high complexity, message
and time complexity.
If you really have unbridled
asynchrony and weights,
this is going to give you
a very costly algorithm.
You're going to see
some exponential is
going to creep in there.
Here's the algorithm for the
asynchronous Bellman-Ford
algorithm.
Everyone keeps track
of their parent.
Their conjecture
distance, and they
have, now, messages that they're
going to send to the neighbors.
Let's say you have a
queue because there
could be successive estimates.
We'll have a queue there.
The key step, the
relaxation step,
is what happens when you receive
a new estimate of the best
distance.
This is weighted distance,
now, from a neighbor.
Well, you look at that
distance plus the weight
of the edge in
between, and you see
if that's better than
your current distance,
just like synchronous
Bellman-Ford.
And if it is, then you
improve your distance,
reset your parent, and send the
distance out to your neighbors.
It's exactly like
the synchronous case,
but we're going to be
running this asynchronously.
And since you're going to be
correcting every time you see
a new estimate, this
is actually going
to handle both kinds
of corrections,
whether it comes because of a
many hop path with a smaller
weight, or whether it just
comes because of the asynchrony.
Whenever you get
a better estimate,
you're going to
make the correction.
Is it clear this
is all you really
need to do in the algorithm,
just what's in this code?
That's the received, and then
the rest of the algorithm
is just you send it out
when you're ready to send.
And then we have the same
issue about termination,
there's no terminating actions.
We'll come back to that.
It's really hard to come up
with invariants and timing
properties, now,
for this setting.
You can certainly have
an invariant like the one
that we just had for
asynchronous breadth-first
search.
You can say that at
any point, whatever
distance you have is an
actual distance that's
achievable along some path,
and the parent is correct.
But we'd also like
to have something
that says, eventually, you'll
get the right distance.
You want to state a
timing property that says,
fine, if you have an at most
r hop path, by a certain time,
you'd like to know that
your distance is at least as
good as what you could
get on that path.
The problem is
what are you going
to have here for
the amount of time?
How long would it
possibly take in order
to get the best
estimate that you could
for a path of at most r hops?
A guess?
I was able to calculate
something reasonable
for the breadth-first
search case,
but now this is going
to be much, much worse.
It's not obvious at all.
It's actually going to depend on
how many messages could pile up
in a channel, and that
can be an awful lot,
an exponential number--
exponential in the number
of nodes in the network.
I'm going to produce an
execution for you that
can generate a huge number of
messages, which then will take
a long time to deliver
and delay the termination
of the algorithm.
First, let's look
at an upper bound.
What can we say
for an upper bound?
Well, there's many
different paths
from v 0 to any other
particular node.
We might have to traverse all
the simple paths in the graph,
perhaps.
And how many are there?
Well, as an upper bound, you
could say order n factorial
for the number of
different paths
that you can traverse
to get from v 0
to some particular other node.
That's exponential in n.
Certainly, it's
order n to the n.
This says that the
number of messages
that you might
send on any channel
could correspond to doing
that many corrections.
This can blow up your
message complexity into n
to the n times the
number of edges,
and your time complexity n
to the n times, n times d,
because on every
edge you might have
to wait for that many messages,
corrected messages, sitting
in front of you.
That seems pretty awful.
Does it actually happen?
Can you actually construct an
execution of this algorithm
where you get exponential
bounds like that?
And we'll see
that, yes, you can.
Any questions so far?
Here's a bad example.
This is a network, consists
of a sequence of, let's say,
k plus 1-- k plus 2, I
guess, nodes, in a line.
And I'm going to throw in
some little detour nodes
in between each consecutive
pair of nodes in this graph,
and now let me play
with the weights.
Let's say on this path,
this direct path from v 0
to vk plus 1, all
the weights are 0.
That's going to be the shortest
path, the best weight path,
from v 0 to vk plus 1.
But now I'm going to
have some detours.
And on the detours I have
two edges, one of weight 0
and the other one of
weight that's a power of 2.
I'm going to start
with high powers of 2,
2 to the k minus 1, and go
down to 2 to the k minus 2,
down to 2 of the 1, to the 0.
See what this graph is doing?
It has a very fast
path in the bottom,
which you'd like to hear
about as soon as you can.
But, actually, there is
detours which could give you
much worse paths.
Let's see how this might execute
to make a lot of messages
pile up in a channel.
My claim is that
there's an execution
of that network in which
the last node, bk, sends 2
to the k messages to
the next node vk plus 1.
He's really going to send an
exponential number of messages
corresponding to
his corrections.
He's going to keep making
corrections for better
and better estimates.
And if all this happens
relatively fast,
that just means
you have a channel
with an exponential
number of messages in it,
emptying that will
take exponential time.
You have an idea how
this might happen?
How could this node, bk, get
so many successively improved
estimates, one after the other?
Well, what's the biggest
estimate it might get?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 2 to the k minus 1.
PROFESSOR: It could
get 2 to the k minus 1?
Well, let's see.
AUDIENCE: Or [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It could do that.
AUDIENCE: Then it's 2 to the k.
PROFESSOR: And it could do that.
AUDIENCE: Plus 2 to the k.
PROFESSOR: Plus 2
to the k minus 2,
plus all the way down
to plus 2 to the 0.
You could be following this
really inefficient path, just
all the detours, before the
messages actually arrive
on the edges on the spine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so you follow
all-- oh, you said 2 to the k,
minus 1, parenthesis.
Yeah, that's exactly right.
AUDIENCE: It's all
right. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: We can't
parenthesize our speech.
All right, so the possible
estimates that bk can take on
are actually 2 to the k-- as you
said, 2 to the k minus 1, which
you would get by taking
all of the detours
and adding up the powers of 2.
But it could also
have an estimate,
which is 2 to the k minus
2 or 2 to the k minus 3.
All of those are possible.
Moreover, you can have
a single execution
of this asynchronous algorithm
in which node bk actually
acquires all those estimates
in sequence, one at a time.
How might that work?
First, the messages
travel all the detours.
Fine, bk gets 2
to the k minus 1.
Then, there's a message
traveling-- well
this guy sends a message
on the lower link.
This guy has only heard about
the messages on the detours up
to that point.
But he sends that
on the lower link,
which means you kind of
bypass this weight of one.
bk gets a little bit
of an improvement,
which gives it 2 to the k
minus 2 as its estimate.
What happens next?
Well, we step one back, and
the node from node k minus 2
can send a message on
the lower link, which
has weight 0, to bk minus one.
But that corrected estimate
might then traverse the detour
to get to node bk.
If you get the correction
for node bk minus 1,
but then you follow the detour,
you haven't improved that much.
You've just improved by one.
This way, you get 2 to the k
minus 3 as the new estimate.
But then, again,
on the lower link,
the message eventually
arrives, which
gives you 2 to the k minus 4.
You see the pattern sort of?
You're going to be
counting down in binary
by successively having
nodes further to the left
deliver their
messages, but then they
do the worst possible thing of
getting the information to bk.
He has to deal with all those
other estimates in between.
If this happens
quickly, what you get
is a pile up of an exponential
number of search messages
in one channel.
And then that
information has to go
on to the next node or the
rest of the network, whatever.
It's going to take an
exponential amount of time,
in the worst case, to
empty that all out.
This is pretty bad, but
the algorithm is correct.
And so how do you learn
when everything is finished,
and how does a
process know when it
can output its own correct
distance information?
How can we figure out when
this is all stabilized?
Same thing as before, we
can just do a convergecast.
I mean this is more
corrections, but it's still
the same kind of corrections.
We can convergecast
and, eventually, this
is going to convergecast
all the way up to the root.
And then the root
knows it's done
and can tell everyone else.
A moral here-- you've
had a quick dose
of a lot of asynchrony--
yeah, if you don't do anything
about it and you just use
unrestrained asynchrony,
in the worst case,
you're going to have
some pretty bad performance.
The question is, what
do you do about that?
There are various techniques.
And if you want to take
my course next fall,
we'll cover some of those.
I'll say a little
bit about the course.
It's a basic-- it's a TQE
level, basic grad course.
We do synchronous, asynchronous,
and some other stuff
where the nodes really know
about something about time.
Here's some of the
synchronous problems--
some like the ones
you've already seen.
Building many other kinds
of structures in graphs,
and then we get into
fault tolerance.
There's a lot of
questions about what
happens when some of
the components can fail,
or they're even
malicious, and you
have to deal with the effects
of malicious processes
in your system.
And then for
asynchronous algorithms,
we'll do not only
individual problems
like the ones you've just seen,
but some general techniques
like synchronizers,
notion of logical time--
that's Leslie Lamport's first
and biggest contribution.
He one the Turing Award last
year-- other techniques,
like taking global snapshots
of the entire system
while it's running.
In addition to talking
about networks,
as we've been doing
this week, we'll
talk about shared memory,
multi-processors accessing
shared memory.
And solving problems that are
of use in multiprocessors,
like mutual exclusion.
And again, fault tolerance.
Fault tolerance then gets us
into a study of data objects
with consistency
conditions, which
is the sort of stuff that's
useful in cloud computing.
If you want to have coherent
access to data that's
stored at many locations, you
need to have some interesting
distributed algorithms.
Self stabilization-- if
you plunge your system
into some arbitrary
state, and you'd
like it to converge to a good
state, that's the topic of self
stabilization.
And depending on
time, there's things
that use time in the
algorithms, and the newer work
that we're working on in
research is very dynamic.
You have distributed
algorithms where the network
itself is changing
during the execution.
That comes up in
wireless networks,
and lately we're
actually looking
at insect colony algorithms.
What distributed
algorithms do ants
use to decide on how to
select a new nest when
the researchers smash their
old nest in the laboratory?
That kind of question.
That's it for the
distributed algorithms week.
And we'll see you--
next week is security?
OK, yeah.